[Applaus]
kennst du das auch
wenn du alles noch warm um's keine angst
in ein mann verbot so viel mehr
[Musik]
diese krise
breitbandausbau auf dem
er will das alles
an die wand
er lenkt die bahn
in den abgrund stück für stück und man
wünscht sich selbst den alex dobrindt
zurück
und dann an die fluten
ist guter jedem ort um das zu verhindern
vor
einen neuen job
die schauen
[Musik]
halt
schädlich und halb so 2
denn als glückskeks auto union als käse
zu sagen
[Musik]
hier
ganz egal
ganz so bissig costa
es gibt so viele
so viel mit
[Musik]
die
mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo
[Musik]
ich bin hartz iv
nachgerade aber wie zu hause sein müssen
du kriegst meinungen und dafür kommst du
zu mir rüber bis und nicht mag ist die
handlichen kurth warum auch nicht
sie selbst
[Musik]
liga
o
musik ist
guck mal
los
auch schon
da wird mir schlecht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sag mal spd wie lange bist du schon
geisel der union
jede wahl zu tun
bist du zweistellig ja dass du schon
doch jetzt
treu
wieder von 30 prozent
[Musik]
da fragen
nicht nur
[Musik]
es liegen hier im optimales bis sie
sagte euch und sei darauf auch nur stolz
doch so sind dann leben
eure polit das 2
[Musik]
o
bis 8
[Musik]
übernimmt
wir haben ein paket erhalten dass das
klima retten soll
da ist es viel zu winzig und nicht mal
zur hälfte voll
bald gibt es zum weihnachtsfest
nie wieder geschenke stress denn dann
schau mir alle beim welt und
ja
zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch
[Musik]
diese
st
noch viel wichtiger
[Musik]
durch das meer zu
ja
es ist nicht gut
[Musik]
red
ganz
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]